Anyway,
thank you for taking time away from your day to come and be here.
This is really cool.
I didn't know that this place existed in certainly would never have known based
on the clandestine outside,
um,
appearance and,
uh,
just had a wonderful time at the cafeteria.
I kind of wished that I worked here.
It's really great.
Um,
so this is my book and it's about a year that I spent traveling around the world
after a very painful divorce,
which is probably redundant.
Um,
but,
uh,
you know,
everybody thinks their divorce was particularly painful and,
and I guess I'm no exception.
And,
uh,
I also followed my divorce with the classic post divorce rebound,
disastrous relationships.
So,
um,
within a year of it all settling,
I was pretty much as they would say in a time and I'm,
so I decided to,
to start all over with my life and get rid of everything.
And I went and traveled around the world for a year and I went to these three
countries,
to Italy,
India and Indonesia.
And in each place,
I was sort of seeking one part of myself that I felt I had lost.
And,
um,
and I wanted to look for it against the backdrop of a culture that specializes
in that,
you know,
so Italy of course was about pleasure.
Where else would you go?
And India was about devotion and Indonesia specifically Bali was about trying to
figure out how you can create a life that incorporates pleasure and devotion in
equal measure.
And um,
the volunteers seem to have some sort of a lock on that.
So I,
I wanted to sort of study how they do it and um,
and that's the book and that's the journey and I'm just going to read one little
short piece of it for you today.
Um,
and then we can just have a conversation and take questions or,
or do whatever you'd like,
play telephone,
whatever.
Um,
but this is from the India section and it's,
um,
it's just,
uh,
some,
some of my thinking about my,
my own,
um,
nascent,
spiritual explorations when I was nine years old,
going on 10,
I experienced a true metaphysical crisis.
Maybe this seems young for such a thing,
but I was always a precocious child.
It all happened over the summer between fourth and fifth grade.
I was going to be turning 10 years old in July and there was something about
this transition from nine to 10 from single digit to double digit.
That shocked me into a genuine existential panic,
usually reserved for people turning 50 I remember that life was passing me by so
fast.
It seems like only yesterday I was in kindergarten and here I was about to turn
10 soon it would be a teenager and then middle aged and elderly and then dead
and soon everybody else would be dead too.
My parents would die,
my friends would die,
my cat would die.
My older sister was almost in high school already.
I could remember her going off to first grade only moments ago.
It seemed in her little knee socks and now she was in high school.
Obviously it would not be long before she was dead.
What was the point of of this?
The strangest thing about this crisis was that nothing in particular had spurred
it.
No friend or relative had died giving me my first taste of mortality.
I had not even yet read Charlotte's web.
This panic I was feeling at the age of 10 was nothing less than a spontaneous
and full out realization of mortalities,
inevitable march,
and I had no spiritual vocabulary with which to help myself manage it.
We were Protestants and not even devout ones at that.
We said grace only before Christmas and Thanksgiving dinner and went to church
sporadically.
My Dad chose to stay home on Sunday mornings finding his devotional practice in
farming.
I sang in the choir because I liked singing.
My pretty sister was the angel and the Christmas pageant.
My mother used the church as a headquarters from which to organize good works of
volunteer service for the community,
but even in that church,
I don't remember there being a lot of talking about God.
This was new England after all,
and the word God tends to make us Yankees very nervous.
My sense of helplessness was overwhelming.
What I wanted to do was pull some massive emergency brake on the universe,
like the breaks I'd seen on the subways during our school trip to New York City.
I wanted to call a timeout and demand that everything just stopped until I could
understand it.
I suppose this urge to force the entire universe to stop in its tracks until I
could get a grip on my thoughts might have been the beginning of what dear
friends of mine have called my control issues.
Of course,
my efforts and worry were futile.
The closer I watch time,
the faster it's spawn and that summer went by so quickly that it made my head
hurt and at the end of every day I remember thinking another one gone and
bursting into tears.
This sadness is one of the great trials of the human experiment as far as we
know,
we're the only species on the planet who had been given the gift or the curse
perhaps of awareness about our own mortality.
Everything here eventually dies.
We're the lucky ones who get to think about this fact every day and how are you
going to cope with this information?
When I was nine,
I couldn't do a thing about it except cry later.
Over the years,
my hypersensitive awareness of time speed led me to push myself to experience
life at maximum pace.
If I were going to have such a short visit on earth,
I had to do everything possible to experience it.
Now,
hence all the traveling,
all the romances,
all the ambition,
all the pasta.
My sister had a friend who used to think that Catherine had two or three younger
sisters because she was always hearing stories about the sister who was in
Africa,
the sister who was working on a ranch in Wyoming,
the sister who was the bartender in New York,
the sister who was writing a book,
the sister who was getting married,
the sister who was getting divorced shortly.
This could not all be the same person.
Indeed.
If I could have split myself into many Liz Gilbert's,
I would willingly have done so in order to not miss a moment of life.
What am I saying?
I did split myself into many Liz Gilbert's all of whom simultaneously collapsed
and exhaustion on a bathroom floor in the suburbs one night around the age of 30
I should say here that I'm aware of.
Not everyone goes through this kind of metaphysical crisis.
Some of us are hardwired for anxiety,
but mortality while others just seem comfortable with the whole deal.
You made a lot of apathetic people in this world of course,
but you also meet some people who seem to be able to gracefully accept the terms
upon which the universe operates and who genuinely do not seem troubled by its
paradoxes.
I have a friend whose grandmother used to tell her there's no trouble in this
world so serious that it can't be cured with a hot bath,
a glass of Whiskey,
and the book of common prayer.
For some people,
that's enough for others.
More drastic measures are required.
I have a friend that I've met here at the Ashram in India named Shawn.
He's one of those people like me who was born with the itch,
the mad and relentless urge to understand the workings of existence.
His little parish in county.
Cork didn't seem to have any of the answers,
so he left the farm and the 1980s to go traveling through India,
looking through for inner peace through yoga.
A few years later he returned home to the dairy farm in Ireland.
He was sitting in the kitchen of the old stone house with his father,
a lifelong farmer and a man of few words and Sean was telling him all about his
spiritual discoveries in the exotic east.
Sean's father listened with mild interest watching the hearth and the fire
smoking his pipe.
He didn't speak at all until Shawn said with excitement dot.
This meditation stuff,
it's crucial for teaching serenity.
It can really save your life.
It teaches you how to quiet your mind.
His father turned to him and said,
kindly,
I have a quiet mind already son,
and then resumed his gaze on the fire,
but I don't,
nor does Sean.
Many of us don't.
Many of us look into the fire and see only inferno.
I need to actively learn how to do what Shawn's father it seems was born knowing
how to do,
how to as well.
Whitman once wrote,
stand apart from the polling and hauling amused,
complacent,
compassion,
dating,
idle,
unitary,
both in and out of the game,
watching and wondering at at all.
Instead of being amused,
though I'm only anxious.
Instead of watching,
I'm always probing and interfering.
The other day in prayer,
I said to God,
look,
I understand that an unexamined life is not worth living,
but do you think I could someday have an unexamined?
The lunch
Buddhist?
Laura has a story about the moments that follow the Buddhist transcendence into
enlightenment.
When after 39 days of meditation,
the veil of illusion finally fell away and the true workings of the universe
where reveal to the great master.
He was reported to have opened his eyes and said,
immediately,
this cannot be taught.
But then he changed his mind and decided he would go into the world after all
and attempt to teach the practice of meditation to a small handful of students.
He knew there would only be a meager percentage of people who would be served by
or even interested in these teachings.
Most of humanity,
he said have eyes that are so caked shut with the dust of deception that they
will never see truth no matter who tries to show it to them.
A few others like Shawn's dot perhaps are so naturally clear eyed and calm
already that they need no instruction or assistance,
but then there are those whose eyes are just slightly caked with dust and who
might with the help of the right master be taught to see more clearly someday.
The Buddha decided he would become a teacher for the benefit of that minority
for those of little dust.
Ideally hope that I'm one of those mid level dust cake I people,
but I don't know.
I only know that I have been driven to find inner peace with methods that might
seem a bit drastic for the general populace.
For instance,
when I told one friend of mine back in New York City that I was going to India
to live in an Ashram in search for divinity.
He sighed and said,
oh,
there's a part of me that's so wishes that I wanted to do that,
but I really have no desire for it whatsoever and I don't know that I have much
choice.
Though I have searched frantically for contentment for so many years in so many
ways and all these acquisitions,
they run you down in the end life.
If you keep chasing it so hard,
we'll drive you to death time when pursued like a bandit will behave like one
always remaining one county or one room ahead of you changing its name and hair
color to elude.
You slipping out the back door of the motel just as you're banging through the
lobby with your newest search warrant,
leaving only a burning cigarette in the ashtray to taunt you.
At some point you have to stop because it won't.
You have to admit that you can't catch it,
that you're not supposed to catch it.
At some point you have to let go and sit still and allow contentment to approach
you.
Letting go of course as a scary enterprise for those of us who believe that the
world revolves only because it has a handle on the top of it,
which we ourselves personally turn and that if we were to drop this handle for
even one moment,
well that would be the end of the universe,
but try dropping it.
This is the message I'm getting an India sit quietly for now and seize your
relentless participation and watch what happens.
The birds do not crash dead out of the sky after all in mid flight,
the trees do not wither and die the rivers to not run red with blood.
Life continues to go on.
Even the Italian post office will keep limping along doing its own thing without
you.
Why are you so sure that your micromanagement of every moment in this whole
world is so essential?
Why don't you let it be?
I hear this argument and it appeals to me.
I believe in it intellectually.
I really do.
But then I wonder with all my restless yearning and with all my hyped up fervor
and this stupidly hungry nature of mine,
what should I do with my energy instead?
That answer is arriving to look for God.
Look for God.
Like a man with his head on fire.
Looks for water.
Thank you.
MMM.
So does anybody have any questions?
The other thing is if,
if,
if the microphone stepping is too complicated,
if you want to say your question,
I guess I could repeat it into here.
Would that also work or is there some sort of super Google technological thing
that I don't understand because I have a really old Motorola cell phone.
Okay.
Um,
anybody have any questions or comments about anything writing this book or other
books or anything better that,
yes.
Um,
the question was how did I pick the three countries and were there others that I
was considering?
Um,
I spent a,
I think when you go on a quest and that that is what this is,
is as Corny as that word might,
might sound,
um,
uh,
it's,
the,
the prospect of questing is something I believe in very much and I believe that
it's a universal human urgency that can be in as strong and some people is the
urge to procreate or protect your kin or build stuff,
you know,
um,
it's,
it can be pretty mighty urgency and I,
and I think you have to prepare for it,
uh,
with a lot of self study.
And so I spent months kind of writing and writing and writing in my journal and
asking myself over and over again as many different forms as possible.
What is it that you really,
really,
really want?
Um,
because that's a kind of hard thing I think for us to admit at times.
And um,
and,
and then I went back and read those journals and saw what kept coming up again
and again and sort of par boil that down to that.
And it appeared that I apparently really wanted to learn how to speak Italian,
you know,
for no logical reason.
It showed up on every page,
you know.
So I thought,
well,
that one's pretty evident and,
and I really wanted to,
um,
I really wanted to focus on my meditation practice in India.
Seemed like a natural place to go for that.
And then also I had a very special reason to go back to valley,
which is that I'd been there a few years ago for a magazine story in this.
I'd had the privilege to meet this ninth generation Indonesian medicine man.
This is kind of amazing old Yoda like character.
And he had dropped this line on me that said that it was my,
um,
apparently it was my destiny to come back there and to teach him English and to
live with his family.
And I grabbed onto that like a life wrote,
but you know,
and um,
um,
he just tossed this thing out and I spent the next almost three years just
trying to figure out how to organize my life around manifesting,
met destiny and getting back there somehow.
And,
um,
and of course I did.
And of course,
you know,
he had no idea who I was when I showed up
as,
as many quests turn out.
You know,
there's always these,
you know,
the,
um,
that's kind of perfect,
mythological,
I'm structuring of how that should go.
Um,
but,
uh,
it was still amazing to,
to be around him and in the end I did end up spending a lot of time with them.
So,
so I was invited to Indonesia and I felt I needed to go to,
to India and I really just wanted to go to Italy and eat a lot of food and learn
how to speak Italian.
And it was happy coincidence that they all began with eye,
which is good on a journey of self discovery.
But,
um,
my friends in Indiana,
we're like,
just come here.
I don't know why you got to
my friends in Islip who were,
were not too impressed,
um,
is there,
so of course,
many other places that begin with I,
but,
uh,
anyway,
that's,
that seemed like the thing to do.
Thanks buddy.
Else?
No.
All right.
Yeah,
we were talking lunch.
Um,
I'm writing a book about marriage,
um,
which is kind of like George Bush writing a book about diplomacy because I
haven't exactly excelled in that.
Um,
but,
uh,
but I am getting remarried and so I would thought that Joan Didion one said that
she writes in order to find out how she feels about things.
And so I'm going to use that,
uh,
at that book as a way to,
to try to understand what indeed that peculiar institution is all about and,
and hopefully knowing more about it,
what might make it go a little better the next time.
So that's what it's about.
Yeah,
sure.
How much of it?
My whole life
I've been sat on vacation that then,
right?
Yeah.
The question is how much of what I learned on the trip have I been able to
incorporate back into my normal life,
including meditation.
I mean,
I think madness would follow anybody who tried to keep an ashram schedule and a
normal life in northeastern United States.
Um,
so I don't know.
I don't harangue myself too much for the fact that I don't meditate five hours a
day anymore or chant for two hours a day or eat really good vegetarian food and
all that kind of stuff.
Um,
but,
uh,
something,
you know,
how can I explain this catharsis?
No Catharsis ever happened without somebody participation.
You know,
people talk about Cathartic experiences,
you know,
somebody has a horrible accident or a horrible heartbreak and it transforms
them.
But,
but not without their,
they're not without their assistance,
you know,
not without them showing up for it.
And I think travel can always seem like such a natural way for people to change
their lives,
but it can't impose change on you.
You know,
you can only kind of will it in and similarly,
whatever.
Beautiful.
Um,
so treasures of selfhood that I found on this journey,
our mind to lose any,
any day,
I feel like it,
you know,
and so I consider it kind of my obligation to,
to hold onto as much of that as I can within reason.
Um,
I would so love to tell you that I get up every day at before dawn and meditate
and I'm half tempted to tell you that because you know,
how the hell would you guys ever know if it's true or not?
But,
um,
in fact it's not true.
Um,
but I,
but I do it more days than I don't.
Um,
and I think that I have for that.
I kind of base it on,
on my writing practice as well.
I would love to say that I write every day,
but I don't,
but I write more days than I don't.
And I think as long as in your life,
you're doing more of what's beneficial to you than not,
then that's probably good enough for,
for what we can do in our normal lives.
Thanks for your question.
Yup.
Back to you asked.
Yeah.
The question is what did they think about coming back to the u s at the end of
my trip I was excited because I had the journey of writing the book to look
forward to.
So that in itself is another kind of adventure in a way.
Um,
and,
and also I was just,
um,
I don't know when I,
when I was at the Ashram,
I remember seeing people who kind of got addicted to,
to exploration without ever coming home,
you know,
like they were,
they were on a spiritual journey kind of their whole lives for like 25 years in
the same Ostrom.
And they were,
and I sort of thought,
is that really the point of these teachings?
You know?
Um,
I mean,
they weren't monks,
they were civilians,
but they were sort of stuck.
I felt in this,
in this cycle of constantly
seeking slash hiding.
And,
um,
and I remember this one girl at the Ash,
I'm coming back from having flown to Chicago to see your family.
And she came back and she was like,
you know,
she was breathing Ostrow mirror.
Like it was pure oxygen.
She was like,
I couldn't wait to get back here because the real world is so screwed up and I
couldn't relate to anybody.
I just wanted to be here with people who understand.
And I just thought the point of this candidate,
all of these teachings and all of that opposed to make reality harder for you,
you know,
it seems like,
um,
any sort of beneficial practice would be one that would make it easier for you
to live in,
in the world.
Um,
and so I was excited to kind of try out my new self and in my old life and,
and see how things had changed.
And,
and indeed I just feel more comfortable in the world and more comfortable in my
skin than ever.
So,
so it's been lovely.
It wasn't,
it wasn't particularly jarring coming back then.
Again,
I didn't come back to a very normal life either.
So,
um,
I,
if I'd had to go back to my marriage and my suburban house,
I think it wouldn't have been quite as quite as much to look forward to that.
Okay.
[inaudible]
oh,
the question is about my last book before this,
which is the last American man where I spent a lot of time actually with this
guy named used is Conway,
who is this sort of modern latter day messianic mountain man guy who lives in
the woods in North Carolina and left home at 17 and has been living in the woods
and living off the land ever since.
And has this completely deranged messianic view of himself as somebody who can
single handedly return America to being in agric agrarian society.
And everybody's going to follow him into the woods and he's so captivating that
you just might think that it was possible.
Um,
but he's also sort of crazy and it's in his way.
and the question was how did that,
how did spending,
I think your question was how to spending time with him affect my own journey in
two ways.
One was that,
um,
did I tell him about this?
Yeah.
I told him I was going to do this and he was,
he was very encouraging.
He's all about,
you know,
the quest.
Um,
uh,
you know,
I spent a lot of time writing about men in my life.
You know,
I worked for spin,
I worked for Gq and,
and my first book was a collection of short stories that seemed to be mostly
about cowboys.
And my second book was a novel about lobster fisherman.
And my third book was this like quintessential American masculine figure.
And I kind of was like,
you know,
a Jay did just need a little time off from the fellows for awhile,
writing about them being married to them,
giving them all my money in divorce settlements,
you know,
to like all,
it's just,
this is just,
I'm a little overwhelmed with this,
you know,
and I,
and I thought that I really wanted to spend some time,
um,
away from that energy.
So in one way it propelled me to want to go off on my own.
And the other is that,
um,
I was really impressed with his self honesty.
Um,
when I wrote that book,
He gave me absolute utter access to his life.
He handed me at one point,
this giant box filled with all his journals and childhood diaries and love
letters from girlfriends who now hated him.
And you know,
all this incredibly intimate stuff that he hadn't even looked at in years.
And he just gave it to me and said,
use any of this.
You know,
he gave me telephone numbers of people that he knew despised him and said,
you should talk to this guy cause he hates me and he thinks I'm a fraud and you
should talk to people who think I'm a fraud.
And he looked at that question himself and he,
you know,
he just,
he just doesn't do things halfway.
And I was,
I was really inspired by the fact that he sort of understood,
if you're going to,
you know,
if you're going to do biography or if you're going to do a memoir,
like do it,
you know,
um,
don't try to turn it into some sort of vanity piece.
And,
and I think that helped me find the result to just tell this story as it
occurred rather than trying to manipulate it or make myself look,
you know,
good.
And in any sort of way.
So that was really those that was inspired.
He was both repellent and inspiring.
And I think that's actually probably a very good general description of him
in total.
Yeah.
In writing web.
Oh,
where do I do my writing?
I used to be a,
yeah,
the,
um,
I mean I've written all over the world,
at this point because I've done so much traveling.
But my preferred,
um,
I mean I've always been,
I think like we're most writers,
I've always been seeking the kind of the perfect womb,
you know,
in which to write and,
um,
and have found different versions of it for different books depending on where I
was living in,
when I was doing.
But my short story collection in my novel,
I wrote almost entirely in the New York public library reading room.
You know,
that beautiful big quiet space,
um,
which is a really nice place to work because you're alone,
but not alone.
You're alone in silence,
but you're not isolated because there's people around and there's this kind of
river of work,
of energy of people studying.
And you would feel guilty to not be in it with them.
Um,
although many times I had this sort of school marm ish guard come and wrap me on
the head for falling asleep in my arm,
my,
you know,
on top of my paperwork,
which you're not supposed to do there.
Um,
but,
but now,
and then my last two books,
this book and the last American man I wrote,
um,
I mean,
when you write a book,
there's years of sort of research and stuff and collecting and that I can do
anywhere,
but when it comes to the actual,
this sort of holy act of sitting down and composing a book,
um,
I need a lot of silence for that.
So I went to an artist's residency in Wyoming.
There's these wonderful sort of retreats that were,
that you go and they take care of you and give you kind of a quiet place to
work.
And so I wrote those books there and now I've just bought a house and I'm hoping
that I can create a quiet enough place in there that I can actually write in my
own home for once,
which I've never been able to do.
Yeah.
So,
but coffee shops would be out of the question for me if only because of the
availability of muffins constantly.
It would be a big muscle.
Anybody else?
Is anybody a writer?
Secrets?
I'm always curious about that.
Yup.
Okay.
Hi.
Um,
I,
I've always,
the question is when studying and Lippert language do take on a different
personality,
um,
yeah,
Italian has a particular,
I think everybody who,
who studies Italian takes on this completely phantasm Phantasmo as,
that's not even a word,
but like this completely romantic.
I mean that in every definition of the word romantic identity,
where you really do think that you're in a Fellini movie and you know that
you're,
you're riding a moped around Rome with your dashing swore,
the boyfriend or so,
there's just something so incredibly sexy about that language.
And that's partially why I think I was so attracted to it because I just felt so
dead.
You know,
I'm after going through divorce and depression and,
and I would go,
I was taking Italian at the new school and I would just come home and lay in the
bathtub and read the dictionary out loud and just put this big flow,
you know,
I'd be like in bubbles and I'd be like,
Ciao.
I let the De,
you know,
um,
you
can't do it without waving your hands around and without.
I'm starting to feel kind of invigorated.
There's,
and there's reasons why as I found out when I was researching the book,
there's reasons why Italian is such a tantalizing language.
Um,
it's not an accident that it's as beautiful as it is.
There were decisions that were made in Italy,
um,
around the 16 hundreds about what was going to be the official language out of
all the dialects.
And there was a kind of counsel,
I mean,
I don't think any other language has this pedigree.
There was a sort of council of intellectuals who got together and basically went
around in Italy what looking for the most beautiful version of a colloquial,
you know,
bastardize Latin.
And it turned out to be Florentine and the language of Dante.
And so it's,
it's a language that was sort of built by a poet and,
and I think that's why it's so appealing and it seems to be universally so.
And when I was in Rome studying,
I found out that every single person in my class who was taking Italian had come
for the same reason because they had no practical justification whatsoever to
learn this thing.
We,
like nobody's boss said,
you have to learn Italian so our business will thrive.
You know,
like it's just not in the sort of vocabulary of commerce,
but,
but people just felt like it would make them feel good too to have those words
and sounds coming out of their mouths and all these stiff German,
you know,
engineers visiting room and wanting to learn because this one guy said,
I want to have the dolce vita,
you know,
and uh,
I was like the Deutsche Shavita though,
you know.
Um,
but,
uh,
this is so,
there's just something very alluring about it.
And,
um,
and I think it helped.
I think it helps change my,
you know,
and I don't think it hurt either that my head as anybody who's gone through
really hard times knows you get stuck in these kind of ruts of thought.
And I don't think it hurt to actually change the language and introduce new
words into your head to try to escape the,
um,
the constant sort of run around of the familiar repetition of destructive
sentences.
Um,
so yeah,
it definitely,
but nobody ever wants to miss took me for being Italian after all that never
happened at all.
Next life.
Okay.
Next life will be Italian.
So yes.
What
happened?
I'm with which man?
From Indonesia.
Uh,
with my,
my sweetheart from Indonesia.
Yeah.
We're getting,
we're getting there.
We're getting married in a few weeks.
Um,
so we're in pretty close contact,
which is good.
Um,
I,
the question is what,
what,
what would be the fourth verb?
That's a really good question.
Eat,
pray,
love.
Um,
well it just somehow reminded me of what my aunt Lou Ann said cause she wished
that I had stayed in Italy the whole time and just call the book,
eat.
Um,
but um,
you know,
actually I would say it would be repeat.
Um,
that's,
that would be the,
uh,
that would probably be the best way to continue to continue your life.
Um,
and it's nice because I just bought a,
I was just telling him a little bit,
or I just bought a church in New Jersey.
So,
um,
and over the top of the 1798 old old church and I decided to have somebody write
in gothic letters over the top,
you know,
eat,
pray,
love.
Cause it seems to be a good location for it.
So,
yeah,
eat,
pray,
love,
repeat,
and so on and so on.
Or maybe remember that would be good too.
So thank you all so much.
I appreciate your questions and your time and good luck on all your quests and
enjoy your coal jobs.
They seem to be from the outside
and thanks for having me.
I appreciate it.